women on television in local news they
have really cool like Rent the Runway
dresses are beautiful they know how to
do their makeup like they were born to
know they have lots of earrings and tall
shoes I wanted to be them my whole life
because if I got to be them or look like
them that was the ultimate Hall Pass
I could just tell stories and I maxed
out a lot of credit cards trying to look
like that but this is the one we've all
been waiting for
it just didn't work good evening I'm
Janice short oh thank you for joining us
you can't have an authentic voice if you
feel like you're in a costume
he's a long time but I did find a way to
unapologetically be myself
[Music]
[Music]
my name is Janice Shortell I'm a
journalist and I host a show here at
kare 11 in Minneapolis Minnesota are you
guys excited when I first moved to
Minneapolis 15 years ago I was not out I
didn't see anyone succeeding in front of
a camera as a gay woman you know I
remember being a little kid when Ellen
came out and it didn't go well Rachel
Maddow wasn't on TV back then so I
swallowed it the first thing I did when
I moved here was get a boyfriend he's
great I haven't really seen him in 15
years oh I still like you Craig I was
actively internally fighting the fact
that I was gay it was like being two
people at once but you can only do that
for so long as a girl growing up in the
world there was a code and in this
industry at least the code was very easy
to see and follow pretty hair perfect
makeup and their outfits look like they
do in the magazines look at my face
look at my face look how there's no
lesbian smirk yet
that was internally difficult but I knew
how to do it
so in my late twenties I started coming
out a little bit at a time I'm not out
on air and when I would have to be on
this side of the camera I got so scared
it was where I was least confident
because I would have to do stuff to look
like somebody I wasn't and how can you
authentically present the news or
someone's story when you take [ __ ]
someone said cut your hair this isn't
working
it went from Bob to short by Kimberly
Kimberly Kim helped me to become Who I
am I've been doing Jana's hair for her
about 15 years when I first met her she
needed a beautifully executed masterful
bob but I would style her hair
differently in order to go out with
friends then we what if she was going
back to work and the two became very
separate it was - Jana's and for me it
was overwhelming because it was two
clients we work together to help her
evolve in to what is now her most
comfortable personal style as she was
assigned this new project in this new
show it became more evident to me that
that was what they were wanting to see
they were wanting to see more of her and
so I absolutely was banging a tambourine
and trying to cheer her on and trying to
move it right along
I loved her coming-out story I think
it's beautiful
when we debuted this show on January
11th of 2016 I felt confident enough to
wear this hair and a David Bowie t-shirt
and I was so scared that the minute I
got off there would be like this group
of people are gonna beat me up or like
send me mail did say take her off the
air none of that happened the applause
were there
I wasn't saying I'm going to be this
like trailblazer I'm just me I mean this
is always who I've been I'm sad that I'm
some sort of anomaly
it seems goofy because I know a lot of
people that look like me but I'm sure
you could call news directors all over
the country that would say my hair is a
problem
we all know the heartbreaking stories
about what happens in the LGBTQ
community to kids figuring out where you
belong and I will be damned if I am not
the person that they need me to be to
get them to that point where they see
themselves and say help
you